latina magazine is mystery and magic and
the importance of mystery in our lives
and some secret things that if I told
you we ruin the entire experience every
few years we hire a guest editor we kind
of look through the wired world and try
to identify people we think are cool or
have especially powerful ideas that we
could kind of bring to the magazine and
kind of have this what we hope is a
powerful collaboration so Jacob was on
our list for a long time the very first
meeting with JJ we decided to do an
entire redesign of the issue we wanted
it to look like an issue of wired that
felt almost like an episode of one of
JJ's TV show it's about to come out of
that jungle is something I can't control
he definitely has a great eye for
graphic design he's got strong opinions
about graphic design and it's a real
type not and then then you go oh that's
okay so you still get this exact layout
but right up here in the corners you
guys so yeah be photographed
we found this amazing photographer a
fine art photographer named Buddha
Cocles Berger who we sent around the
world to photograph our mystery issue
photo essay so cover to cover it's like
it's the most visually intense to issue
of wire that I've ever worked on in my
three years here we have Randall
Sullivan running about a an American
Stonehenge we have JJ who's made a
contribution and we also have his
screenwriter who worked together with
the great graphic novelist paul pope to
create a special star trek comic that
that ties it into the movie and also
takes us back to previous Star Trek
television shows when you think about it
wired is about mystery and puzzles and
the search for meaning inside science
and technology so it actually was a
perfect fit with with what JJ works with
in his work the need for mystery the
role it plays in our lives why we enjoy
it why we need it and some factors of
that are actual stories about enigmas
things we don't understand the
neuroscience of why magic works we've
gone out to some of the greatest most
renowned puzzle creators in the world
people like Will Shortz who does NPR
sunday editions puzzle master sequence
and does the New York Times crossword
puzzle we've gone out to dr. su doku
himself thomas schneider to create a
crazy very very geek friendly version of
a Sudoku puzzle it's like nothing you've
seen before there are puzzles that are
really really obvious and then there are
puzzles that are less obvious and beyond
that there there's mysteries galore
almost on every page there's a mystery
to be had there are little things that
seemed amiss where you have a maybe a
border on a picture that that doesn't
quite line up or something that seems
misspelled or a letter missing and I can
tell you that everything in there is
intentional so the closer you look the
more you'll find they'll be on fire
because of this like it is the craziest
thing I've ever seen